my youtube schedule is changing again
hello believe nation and all you loyal
subscribers I love you guys and I'm
super excited to announce that I'm
changing my youtube schedule again
adding more videos and move into a three
video per day schedule on weekdays and
two videos on the weekend and I'm going
to explain to you today what you can
expect because it launches tomorrow so
saturday morning at 7am instead of the
top 10 series coming out it's going to
be a new series called environment and
the idea here is that a lot of people
you know your environment sucks you
don't have greatness around you and in
order to be great you need to be
surrounded by greatness and so we're
going to be compiling a whole bunch of
quotes and thoughts from successful
entrepreneurs and you deal with this is
not to watch the whole thing as a video
but to have it as the background however
does it back on for your life back room
for your business if you're driving a
work or you're at the office or just
relaxing you have it on the background
to have constant reminders to push
yourself and be great saturday at 8pm is
going to be my Evans book update instead
of its usual Sunday spot Sunday morning
is a new series and again instead of the
top 10 it's going to be a new series
called believe life and here we're
looking at how can you make your life
better not just inside of
entrepreneurship but how can we talk
about meditation or fitness or other
things related to your life that you
want to learn about and again bringing
in some of the best thoughts from across
YouTube and around the world to help you
live a better life sunday night at eight
o'clock is going to be my personal
series the life with Evan instead of
saturday now we get to the weekdays
weekday mornings will stay at the ends
press 0 7 a.m. i know you guys love
those coming out so we're not touching
that five days a week and espresso kicks
off your mornings then that noon and
these times are all Eastern at noon
we're launching the lunch and earn
series and that's replacing the ass Evan
series it's the same kind of concept
where I'm answering questions answering
your question sharing my thoughts and
hopefully you can spend your lunch time
with me
me to get some ideas to help you grow
your business so I'm excited about that
new lunch and earn spot then you might
be thinking well you took out the top
tens out of the weekends I love the top
tens what happened to them they're going
to be coming out now five days a week
instead of two every weekday at eight
o'clock eastern we're putting out the
top 10 series so that's the new schedule
I'm really excited to see how it goes we
may have a few bumps and bruises along
the way and I appreciate your support
your ideas or feedback to suggestions as
we figure it all out thank you so much
for your ongoing support and loyalty if
you want to let me know what you think
about the new plans leave it in the
comments below thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon